you've done a lot of stuff in your
career if someone has actually never
seen anything you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why wow good question uh I guess
money Heist just because yeah it's a one
passion
makes me a library do we hear uh yeah I
would say so for fans of money Heist I I
have to do a follow-up if you don't mind
what do you think would surprise people
to learn about the actual making of
money Heist that they wouldn't know just
from watching the show it was the
history of a failure
we I had an
um we had a um
guy
that came down to the set and says uh
you guys got a rap because this is
you we're not going to do 18 episodes
we're gonna do 15. you guys this is it
we're done you your numbers are
ridiculous and we're taking you out of a
screen so it is the history of a failure
it's so it's crazy I know isn't it yeah
also the fact that the show it was going
to be 18 episodes that's what we signed
for and he ended up being 15 because one
executive director came down to us and
said
I believe in the show but your numbers
are very low and you guys are out
that's nobody knows this you're the
first one to know it's bizarre and then
the show of course you know I heard a
call yeah I heard it's popular I heard
people around the world watch some
people know me right I I like in the
last five years I've sang like three or
four autographs around the world
it's completely no no the biggest show
in the history of Netflix yeah also it's
being remade around the world it's uh
the Korean thing yeah I am I haven't
seen it uh we promote it but I haven't
seen it I heard it's not that right who
was the most excited in your life that
you were going to be working with
Jennifer Aniston and Adam Sandler when I
received the email from my
um agent I was flying from Spain to
Chile and I was doing a a layover in
Peru
that can really read well with myself
without my glasses so it's like
Okay
and like guy do you have a new shirt
kind of I was like all right but okay a
movie with Jennifer Aniston and Adam
Sandler but where's where is the
audition he can't find it he he forgot
to send me the the
you know the audition Piece
it ended up it wasn't an addition piece
they just offered me a job and I just
couldn't understand why uh then I knew
that one of the producers
Jim and the director uh Jeremy they were
big fans of money Heist they were big
fans and they loved my character for
some reason
I know I know this guy has to be in our
mood and uh I I did an audition for this
I was I had just got it what actually
I've I've been fortunate enough to
interview Adam and Jennifer a few times
they're the nicest people
um aren't they it's quite it's crazy how
old is it yes so I want to know what
actually surprised you about working
with them because everyone says how
grounded they are and how nice and you
know I my worst the first day on set
when I arrived with the driver
I didn't know anybody I just landed in
in Hawaii and I was like and then you
know it was this all this uh covet thing
going on and you know so you had to be
in a trailer do the thing and then
they'd gone back half an hour later with
the results and I was like
what am I doing here like like what am I
doing here why am I here
uh this is wrong I'm not good enough
this is I I saw the set and uh
everything and I think
this is there's something wrong about
this you had a little bit of imposter
syndrome
holding with you that is the word
impossible and
we had a rehearsal when we all clear
from coven whatever we had a rehearsal
I know that feeling of
being imposter syndrome of being beneath
which I am still to this day I believe
those but it just went away because they
make you feel that you are not just
their equal but even better than them
and that's the greatness of this too
that they are so humble
in a legitimate and honest way not just
to be in a humble guy no they they
really are those people and I've never
met anybody in my life and I work with a
lot of stars
but these two
are the best human beings I have ever
encountered yeah everyone says that it's
so refreshing
um I definitely have to ask you a little
bit about your character uh and the fact
that you are constantly pursuing
Jennifer Aniston through the movie when
you read all that and and it's been
caught a lot but anyway but uh yeah yeah
yeah but like I'm a womanizer in in the
movie sure just the movie go on yeah
okay uh football player
um you know I chase I have like 80
kids with 80 different women uh no this
guy would would have been if if this was
real time lifetime he would be or he
would be canceling him he's like no dad
no he's he's done he had a lot of fun
doing it because I understand that guy
I not necessarily I am that guy but I
love football that's my passion
um
women too that's what I said it's real
life go on I'm joking with you I'm
joking and uh I was like I I know this
guy he's Spanish he's a football ex
football player as all the women he
wants and uh I I understand that guy I
can play that guy and then the Press of
the gift
because he's not so much about the
character man it's it's about
the the tempo that the Finesse of doing
comedy
with this too and I learned so much
character is just a character is that
this is not Hamlet okay all right this
is not to be or not to be but
I had fun and they made it
um very much
fun I have to rap I'm just going to say
congrats and I wish you nothing but the
best